finally the night they get their hands
on the prize
Chelsea were at Anfield providing yet
another guard of honor to the undisputed
champions of England Europe and the
world and they showed why there was
nothing riding on this game
but the performance matched the occasion
the presentation on the cop afterwards
will be led by Sir Kenny Dalglish he was
still playing the odd game when he
managed the last Liverpool team to win
the league title here in 1990 the club
and Merseyside Police had urged people
to celebrate at home and most did many
chose to go to a venue where they could
spread out but still he's performed
absolute miracle I can I would do I
agree we do what he said it was going to
like this I'll move all the shitty
in four and a half years here Jurgen
Klopp has met the sky-high expectations
at this club they also expect him to do
it again next year I think we played
better last year consistently we got 97
points we won the Champions League this
year there are games when you know we've
won but we may not have played well so
it's not the seasons for a two year
consistence the level of consistency
which has blown everybody away there
will be a parade and a mass celebration
in this city when Coe bid restrictions
allow but it is still their trophy to
live
[Applause]